you see a the most famous Armenian like
Kim Kardashian become single right
do you like you try to you know bring
her over back home you mean
I mean if I could get in the room
I would have mine you know what I'm
saying because I just saw a clip
somewhere of like I think it was her mom
was like trying to like who could find
her that's like an old uh I know it's
old it's old like a cup of no way to
Kardashian yeah yeah yeah yeah her mom
was trying to hook him up with my boys
the Platinum brothers or one of them you
know okay okay Motorsports because they
do all their cars they've been for like
mad years shout out to George and Jack
so yeah there was a there was an episode
with Chris I don't know if that was real
it was for the show but it was hilarious
every time I see it I don't know if Kim
was interested at the time but that [__]
was funny I think you should give it a
shot man I think she's I mean she's
single you know yeah you just shoot her
a DM just be like hey shooter only has
200 million followers she should dm with
you know the Armenian flag and be like
hey I'm a fan yeah I'm sure I'm the only
one that's gonna do that let me take it
get some good food in Glendale
where would you I was gonna say you
would take her to rafis I mean
she's obviously Armenian but I don't
know if she's super tapped into the
Armenian Armenian like restaurants and
culture I don't know maybe she is so
you're saying that'd be the restaurant
so I would probably you know I'd be
giving rafi's way too much love like
every time I've never gotten a discount
but every time someone asks me I bring
up raffies you know and I post that's
what everybody always says rafi's is
amazing I was there the other day um
Carousel is another one both in Glendale
yeah I haven't really thought about
where I would take him
start thinking we've got to Manifest
this man on this manifest we've been
manifesting [__] lately so the Kim K you
be you guys would you guys would
literally own Armenia we would bro you
can could go with own Army she's like I
already own Armenia
I don't need you I'm a billionaire leave
me here yeah yeah that's crazy
um what was like for you outside of Nas
you've done some big records with you've
done records with some [__] Legends
like what what what uh
is the record that almost happened
or that you thought Mike could still
happen in the future that you haven't
worked with somebody in terms of just
like an artist because I know we had
discussed in the past you would almost
did something with Eminem back in the
day yeah but today that's crazy
um the probably the craziest almost
story was nipsy
um
because I had just started working with
Scott I didn't have literally none of
these features yet right we just start
cooking up and my partners you know
that's from the Cannabis game he just
randomly brought up like you know I'm
mad cool with Nipsey and the team and
this is when Victory lat was everywhere
they've seen my favorite rapper like
especially then right that album like I
was like yo Nipsey to one and um
he's he called him right on the spot you
know what I'm saying and he's like you
know we work in this and this and that
let me introduce you to my guy you know
so briefly introduced us we started
slowly building that relationship never
met in person yet right and then he
connected me one of his team members I
send the record over and he hit me back
saying yo nip [__] with it you know
he's down to do it
um I'm like yo if it's possible I'm
trying to be in the studio all these
features except meth and French all the
others we're in the studio in the studio
together you know what I'm saying crazy
it's a different energy bro like I feel
like the Nas record would have been
wouldn't have been that if it wasn't if
you guys weren't vibing with each other
on the hook together and [__] like that
so you know if I can which nowadays
obviously not easy especially for like a
big artist like that but anyway I asked
him and he's like yeah no problem
I'ma hit you you know top of the week
and we set it up
and that Sunday he got he got killed bro
damn yeah crazy crazy story
um so yeah rest in peace rest in peace
besides that yeah I've been around a lot
of people and it's like
um you know me and Ross talked about
doing something at one point
you know I learned like you can't take
too long when these opportunities come
take off we talk about this in the last
interview it was a brief combo with
takeoffs like yo send me something
because I had offset and I had cuevo
um
I'm like yo you're the only me go out
and do a record yet you know what I mean
he's like yo what we doing send me
something and I lagged on it you know
what I'm saying but it's not just
because I lagged it's like I felt like I
didn't have the right record yet because
I hate having mediocre records I see
this all the time with a big name for
sure if you click on it like it's cool
that doesn't do nothing for you you know
I mean for your career it's a waste of
Smash If you have really something
undeniable and then you have a big name
on it it just helps then then you got
something you know what I'm saying